when you think of a filter you imagine  something's being removed you might  imagine a filter for light would make  the light dimmer if you add a second  filter all light gets blocked but what  if we add a third filter in between all  of a sudden there's light passing  through again  so more filters sometimes means more  light  the middle one actually changes the  single 90 degree angle into two separate  angles that total to 90 degrees maybe  two 45 degree angles or a 30 and a 60 or  a 75 and a 15 none of which are 90 and  the smaller the angle the brighter the  light so let's say you have 91  polarizers all oriented one degree apart  what happens then well over 97 percent  of the light will make it through it's  called the light polarization paradox it  makes you second guess whether or not we  should call these things filters because